voici aujourd'hui 14 astuces pour venir
prolonger l'autonomie de la batterie de
votre smartphone huawei parce que
souvent de smartphones à moi ou un autre
commence à nous lâcher et là ça va pas
du tout alors soit vous avez une prise
électrique pas très loin de vous le
branchez pour charger et surtout vu
aujourd'hui la vitesse à laquelle
surcharge les smartphones grâce au bloc
de chars 65 watts et compagnie bref ça
va vite c'est bien et ça c'est rassurant
mais si vous n'avez plus de prises
électriques vers vous si vous n'avez pas
votre blog de charger de vous et s'il
vous reste encore quelques bonnes heures
à passer avant de croiser une prise eh
bien ça serait quand même cool de
croquettes ces quelques astuces ça vous
évitera quelques galères alors on dit
dans
ma première astuce apparaître un petit
peu ridicule mais je vous assure je vous
assure que des fois on y pense tant
qu'on fait pas suffisamment attention
quand vous n'avez plus beaucoup de
batterie la première chose à faire est
bien c'est plus utilisés vous l'utilisez
plus vous le laisser tranquille vous le
poser sur une table dans un coin quelque
part vous mettez loin de vos yeux vous
ne l'utilisez pas parce que quand on va
l'utiliser on va venir taper dans la
batterie forcément donc si vous laissez
tranquille vous devez pouvoir gagner
quelques pourcentages de batterie qui
pourrait potentiellement vous sauver la
vie astuce numéro 2 baisser la
luminosité de son smartphone à saintes
où tu peux paraître un petit peu con
mais je vous assure que c'est
extrêmement important si vous baissez la
luminosité et bien vous allez venir
gagner en autonomie pourquoi et bien
tout simplement parce que les écrans ça
consomme énormément regardez là je suis
plein match consomme à fond et plus
jeunes individus et et plus je vais
gagner alors on peut vous paraître un
peu ridicule comme ça lorsque vous
passez d'une luminosité comme ça à une
luminosité comme ça on voit pas beaucoup
vous avez doublé votre autonomie et si
vous voulez aller encore plus loin vous
baissez vous baissez vous baissez vous
blesser en fait moi ce que je vous
conseille c'est devenir bcge est ce que
vous n'y voyez quasiment plus rien qu'on
voit un tout petit peu que vous allez
doublé voire un petit peu plus
l'autonomie de votre smartphone vous
permettra d'aller encore plus loin et
croyez moi qu'une belle ça consomme
surtout l'agent d'iphone 13 pro mac ça
consomme énormément et si vous êtes
aussi sur un smartphone comme celui là
c'est très très grand je pourrais avoir
un peu l'exemple un peu extrêmes si vous
prenez un samsung galaxy cette folle de
trois ça consomme énormément donc
baisser baisser baisser la luminosité
pour aller beaucoup plus loin troisième
astuces qui découle de la deuxième
astuce c'est de mettre la lune auzits et
automatique ou luminosité adaptative
comme vous voulez regardez par exemple
ici que montre un grand écran c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour venir voir ce
qui se passait bien vous venez coché la
petite case ici qui s'appelle luminosité
adaptative vous cliquez dessus et comme
ça va venir régler automatiquement alors
vous voyez là tout de suite il ya quand
même beaucoup d'éclairage à elvire noter
si vous êtes dans des conditions vous
avez un petit peu moins de lumière l
avenir se baisser se baisser ce baiser
tranquillement donc ça c'est si vous
avez un peu batterie encore sur un petit
peu tranquille mais si vous êtes
vraiment a pas beaucoup de batteries et
bien vous le bc comme tout à l'heure
vous le bc manuellement pour être
tranquille quatrième astuces et non des
moindres c'est de baisser la résolution
de votre smartphone alors par des fonds
il ya beaucoup de smartphones qui seront
en full hd il a certains qui ont
carrément du wqs hd plus que je vous
conseille si vous êtes en wqs des plus
est de 2 c la résolution passée en full
hd vous allez consommer moins parce que
vous allez voir moins de pixels allumé
donc penser vraiment à baisser la
résolution de votre smartphone pour dire
gagner un petit peu au niveau
d'autonomie 5e astuces de la même
manière vous avez baissé la résolution
d'écran de votre smartphone venait
baisser le taux de rafraîchissement
regardez ici par exemple l'âge venant
fluidité des mouvements et là qu'est ce
que je vois je vois quoi que je suis en
fluidité adaptative alors ça c'est
vachement bien parce que je pouvoir
aller entre du 60è 90 hier jusqu'à 120
hertz son cas c'est vachement coup
lorsque je veux venir jouer à des jeux
mais lorsque j'ai besoin d'économiser la
batterie montrent parfois que ça m'a plu
du tout je viens me mettre ici en
standard et standard c'est quoi c'est du
60 hertz fixe je bouge pas je reste là
je vais économiser je vais venir moins
consommer parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
en fait les airs c'est le nom d' images
que vous avez par seconde vous êtes donc
vous dirais tu rentres du 60 images par
seconde 80 des images par seconde et ses
120 images par seconde et plus vous avez
des images par seconde et plus vous
allez venir ap dans la batterie du
smartphone dont vous le bc ou passer en
60 images par seconde en fixe comme ça
vous allez venir gagner en autonomie et
ça c'est vachement bien si c'est
l'astuce déjà déjà la sixième astuces
vous passez en mode sombre oui pourquoi
et bien parce que vous avez aujourd'hui
deux types d'écran que l'avenir bas vous
avez soit une technologie oled à savoir
que sur un écran oled un pixel noah est
un pixel est un nom que lorsque je passe
antenne fondre là et bien tout ce qui
est noir a volé des pixels et un nom qui
ne concerne absolument pas d'énergie et
si vous êtes sur une dalle lcd ça va
baisser baisser baisser la luminosité ça
va toujours venir consommer un petit peu
mais pas énormément dans tous les cas
c'est bon pour votre batterie vous allez
aller beaucoup plus loin au niveau
l'autonomie donc une fois de plus ce
mode sombre alors après comme la ici sur
ayew avoir un mode automatique ça va
rester clair jusqu'au coucher du soleil
ou ça passe en note sombre c'est plus
pour vous pour la fatigue oculaire par
jour mais pour la batterie mais pour
votre batterie vous passez en mode sont
comme ça vous êtes tranquille certaines
astuces n'utilisez pas les applications
qu'ils consomment énormément alors on me
prête forcément on fait des photos mais
pour autant les photos ça consomme
énormément tu va concerner quoi le cpu
ça va consommer le gpu ça utilise les
capteurs ça utilise l'écran bref c'est
le full options ça consomme énormément
si vous n'avez plus beaucoup de
batteries si vous avez besoin de venir
l'économiser ne fait pas de photos
restez tranquilles pareil de la même
manière n'allait pas jouer à des jeux
elle n'est pas faire du gaming ça
consomme beaucoup ça va taper dans les
ressources n'allait pas sur les réseaux
sociaux n'est pas faire d'elle refresh
n'avait pas garder vos e-mails rester
tranquille si vous avez vraiment besoin
de gagner en autonomie vous posez votre
smartphone vous n'utilisez pas ou
lorsque vraiment vous en avez absolument
besoin mais quand je dis absolument
besoin pas tik tok satuc toc c'est pas
absolument besoin alors qu'on laisse de
côté mon sauf si c'est pour venir me
voir au top auquel cas on peut 8e as
tous il utiliser des applications qui
fonctionnent écran éteint venir écouter
de la musique par exemple consomme moins
parce qu'un écran ça consomme beaucoup
passer un appel téléphonique avec votre
application d'appels téléphoniques et
non pas et quoi de ça pour quoi pour
votre écran soit éteint utiliser des
applications écrans est un ça peut
paraître tout bête mais croyez moi que
c'est important 9e astuces peau neuve
pour la 9 c kom sa neuvième astuces et
bienvenue à activer le mode d'économie
d'énergie c'est extrêmement important à
ces attaques le premier réflexe qu'on a
mais pour autant on veut pas forcément
vous venez ici dans votre batterie
regardez vous avez un très bon mode si
sur un os qui s'appelle le mode
d'économie d'énergie mais vous aurez la
même chose sur android vous cliquez là
et là paf qu'est ce qui se passe votre
smartphone ne va pas travailler en tâche
de fond il n'a pas venir récupérer vos
emails il va pas venir télécharger tout
ce dont il a besoin il ne fera pas mise
à jour il va rester cool à la cale et
peña en attendant que vous vouliez
décocher ses petites cases là et vous la
déco fréquents et bien quand vous serez
chargé au maximum à des foires dans leur
s il vient décoché automatiquement
lorsqu'il est suffisamment chargée et ça
aussi c'est cool et si tout ça suffit
pas eh bien j'ai une dixième astuces la
10e as tu sais quoi bah c'est ça et moi
d'avion vous passez en mode avion
s'adapte ou couper tout couper tout ce
qui est radio s'est coupé c'est vrai
vous conservez le wifi et bluetooth et
si ça ne suffit pas vous me déconnecter
le wifi et le bluetooth si vous regardez
juste vos smartphones pour me regarder
l'heure si vous n'avez pas de montre
voilà comme ça au moins vous êtes
peinard ça nous emmène à une onzième à
tous larosace tu ça peut paraître un peu
bête mais on va aller encore plus loin
on va venir les tendres comme ça vous
allez consommer
1 0 plus tôt ça c'est vraiment
l'habitude de dernière chance est
vraiment vous n'avez plus rien plus rien
une batterie et vous est donné aux coups
de fil ultime ou de regarder les
horaires du bus ou de quoi que ce soit
que ça vous servira vraiment en dernier
recours pensez à éteindre votre
smartphone si vous n'avez plus du tout
vous l'éteignez voudra lui mais juste
pour pouvoir faire une dernière action
avant de recharger comme ça c'est bien
12e astuce c'est pas ça qui va être là
pour révolutionner ahmed a contribué
tout à petit petit bout par petit bout à
venir économiser la batterie de votre
smartphone vous coupez les notifications
comme ça vous n'aurez pas de
notification votre écran ne saluera pas
votre smartphone ne sonnera pas aux
smartphones ne vibrera pas il à venir
moins consommer et vous emmènerez un peu
plus loin ça reste un énorme mais quand
il a plu beaucoup de batteries tout est
bon à prendre 13e astuces vous passez
votre smartphone en mode oui oui alors
même si c'est en plein jour vous pouvez
passer en mode nuit pourquoi parce que
selon les expériences logiciel certains
constructeurs ont vraiment optimisé le
mode nuit en disant ok c'est la nuit on
se repose on n'a plus besoin d'aller
faire des mises à jour on n'a plus
besoin d'aller rechercher des
notifications on n'a plus besoin de
faire tout ce travail en arrière-plan
vous activez le mode nuit comme ça vos
smartphones va faire le minimum le
strict nécessaire et vous viendrez
prolonger l'autonomie de votre batterie
allez 14e astuces 14e astuce c'est comme
ça on n'y pense pas forcément mais si
vous êtes en extérieur vous attendez
vous a plu beaucoup de batteries et bien
rentrer au chaud pourquoi parce que les
smartphones n'aime pas des températures
extrêmes alors vous êtes un forcément à
-15 en extérieur en train de vous gelez
sur la banquise mais s'il fait froid ou
s'il fait trop chaud rester un endroit
tempéré pourquoi une fois de plus les
smartphones n'aime pas les températures
qui fluctuent soit trop vers le haut
soit trop vers le bas une bonne vieille
température tempérée sous permettra
d'emmener votre smartphone plus loin
voilà vous connaissez les quatorze
excuse pour venir économiser la batterie
vos smartphones j'ai pas si vous en
connaissez nos doubles et marqué bien
évidemment juste en bas dans les
commentaires je vous ai pris des astuces
de bon sens des choses qui me paraissait
important de choses que j'ai appris au
fur et à mesure de mon usage de mon
expérience dans le monde magique des
smartphones j'espère que ça vous aura
aidé si vous avez des pôles échéant gros
pouce un pouce vers le haut et bien
évidemment vous abonner si ce n'est pas
encore fait qu'elle soit petit bouton
rouge qui est juste là actionner la
cloche pour rectifier dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
vachement bien nous embrasse prenez soin
de vous et à très bientôt mis beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup d'amour et ça c'est
important et très bonne idée et beaucoup
d'amour et beaucoup de joie et bonheur
dans votre famille
[Musique]